ciao a tutti vi è tornati sani the
stories oggi un video al grandissima
richiesta e cioè line bassi senza colla
meno le chiedete sempre in continuazione
e da un sacco pieno di faccio come ho
già fatto tantissimi ma è comunque il
tipo di video che mi richiede che di più
in assoluto
quindi o si dà da fare un altro video in
flash senza colla ed e volete vederne
altri magari quelli che in cui il sole
con tre ricette lasciato quella è sempre
sui tirocini 10 mian ex ha trovato è
stato del consiglio certi aspetti con la
potete scrivere una rete pure nei
commenti allora ho voluto fare questo
tema senza collo perché l'ho visto dal
canale ma a casa lo scherzetto ai box in
pratica è la stessa persona al 2000 navi
e una ragazza carinissimo per una
collaborazione a schemi e super bravo
nickname
niente è stato questo metodo di restare
senza bolla in pratica lo slime clio e
trasparente senza con lei senza maschera
brindisi perché intendersi vita la
maschera berni costituire con la
trasparenza che sapete difficile da
trovare tra l'altro dopo con l'asta
coordinata su amazon ed era per niente
guida funziona masper perfezionerà anche
un per me allora
mentre si devono usare delle bollette un
ordine su amazon
vi lascio diminuirli che descrizione
come sempre non ho mai proposto perché
pochi ne sono in un periodo di provarle
vedere come funzionano e poi dove
troviamo andiamo a fare allora aprirle
prima
[Musica]
perché non va si sono rotte tutte
vabbè sostenerci
perché internet è procura rimanere tra
tram per te seguito allora sofia le
bolle in aria in alto aspetto qualche
secondo vanno le cose diventano
trasparenti puoi prenderlo e proprio in
alto vediamo
e rimasta stati ma cosa possono vedere
tipo tedesco a prenderla
allora perche non e vero bastato un
prodotto difettoso riuscito a prenderlo
quindi bisogna aspettare un pochino
questi solidificano pro guardate un po
gli partendo fa non ha potuto di lato be
alimenti oltre alla patente
quindi si possono prendere in mano
vedete è scoppiato
non toccarla
[Musica]
figo proprio ball vi lasciano una specie
di residuo in pratica al daily spiegava
nel video che svetta c'è del di via ed è
per questo che si solidificano quindi si
può fare non è trasparente che questo
evento sia fisico che amare le polle
solide anche se ne dura notato come
propria può fare questo flirt
trasparenza ed intasare la bolla marco
tronto punto le folle che poteva passa
gialla se li metterebbero male attrarre
vediamo questo giallo ma perché tutti i
lati renderle meglio sulla meglio
neanche dalla francia perché molto caldo
quaresima degli spettatori per carletto
se avessi con gatto lo stile purtroppo
comunque eco assist e le bolle bene
allora innanzitutto c'è da dire che
questo liquido questo liquido è super
trasparenti patiti lei quando so che
questo è trasparente che sembrava ancora
trasparente dentro quando offerente non
con uno spareggio fa sono quelli lì
guardateli netta al cliente normale e
questo è molto il mattino perché si è
illuminato con qualcun altro
[Musica]
ecco vado raggiungo un pochettino di
acqua così mi sento un po più grande e
pesca e veniamo
proviamo ad attivarlo videoproduzione
ora non ha schivato speriamo che
funzioni ma stesso pcb perché mi sono
molto danno fa ok ora ho detto latino
storia non sono i riferimenti avrei
dovuto sbriciolare meglio il carbonato
perché ha fatto dei coloni va bene che
il clear slide quindi vado a toglierle
tali si siano quasi saputo un bel po per
attivarlo è un pò di più ma partita
piaciuto quel po di acqua
comunque è stranissimo perché la
consistente tipo quella del cicli che
sembrano qua sembra quello è proprio
super leggeremo si sia perché
aggiungiamo ma alla fine non è un sito
così tanta
immaginarlo un pochettino ora ovviamente
non è trasparente perché ci sono un
sacco di balle e dobbiamo aspettare un
polo con le bolle superficie proprio
super gt l'incredibile anche perché
dobbiamo aspettare un po guardate un po
non mi aspettavo che uscite uno tra
hamsik lì come quelli acquatici nuvola
aspettava un proprio cioè una chat è
veramente che sia diventata così in
genere come con la normale non riesco a
farli così cicli leggeri e giamo quindi
non se non figurasse colorarono per
madinat ero nella scatolina e farlo
diventare trasparente ma magari non
condividiamo quanto diventa trasparente
quindi ora vado a chiuderlo nella
scatolina aspettiamo un pochino erika
non succedere come diretta
contro tutti servizi e bellissimo essere
stabili ecco qua il nostro slime pronto
allora sono successe di cose nel
frattempo allora l'ho messo dentro una
scatolina più grande però siccome questa
stanza ci sono tipo 40 gradi a tirar
fuori un po di acqua si è messo sciolto
non essere una scatolina più piccola ed
eccolo qua ecco perché si è
rimpicciolito così tanto si è schiarito
un po però è un po non so se riuscito a
vederlo è un po opaco giallino non è
completa se super trasparente ma non so
se perché devo aspettare un po di più
comunque vediamo come che ha una bella
consistenza è rimasto poco appiccicoso
però un pizzico zoe più bello visto bene
è uscito lo slime vorrebbe un po ok ora
sembra più trasparenti mese che sembra
un po che trasparente che bello
[Musica]
cosa sei un po più succoso ma appunto
caldo quindi cosa ne pensate di questo
slime scrivetemi nei commenti questo
slam con le bolle il sono contenta
criscito è un nuovo metodo per fare lo
slime senza colla mi piace che sia
abbastanza trasparente comunque devo
aggiungere un po di attiva toria forse
allora lasciate un like se volete vedere
altri slime senza colla scrivetemi pure
nei commenti le vostre ricette di slam
senza colla se questo video raggiungi
10.000 light andrò a fare le vostre
ricette di slide senza colla mettere un
like alle ricette che vi piace di più
che dio non pare prima quelle con blinds
questo che mi interessano più di tutte
ora vi lascio quattro cartellini se vi
potete cliccare per vedere i prossimi
video mi altri geni senza colla e
divertenti medie challenge click quello
che preferite e buona visione io rimango
a giocare con questi slime con le bolle